what would you do for the power to fly
how about shedding your skin and
dissolving your own muscles now believe
it or not that gruesome process is how
caterpillars earn their wings here's
what you might not know about what's
inside a caterpillars cocoon contrary to
popular belief this is not a cocoon only
certain moths built cocoons which are
like a silky sleeping bag that covers
the insect this on the other hand is
what's called a chrysalis
it's not a sac or a pouch it's actually
the caterpillars own body when it's time
for the transformation to begin the
caterpillars body ramps up production of
a hormone called Ekta zone and that
causes it to cast off its outer coating
sort of like how a snake sheds its skin
and underneath is a hard shell similar
to the exoskeleton of a beetle after
that life for the little caterpillar
gets easy first it releases enzymes
called caspases these rip apart and
dissolve cells in its muscles digestive
system and other organs but the enzymes
don't quite liquefy all of the
caterpillar they leave key structures
intact like breathing tubes at the same
time specialized cells called imaginal
discs start waking up before the
chrysalis stage these discs were kept
dormant by a series of hormones in the
caterpillars body but once the
transformation begins those hormone
levels take a nosedive giving these
discs the opportunity to do what they do
best build a butterfly you see each disc
contains the genetic recipe to form a
different adult body part starting from
the inside out after one week the
digestive system of the butterfly is
well on its way and by day 16 the adults
legs wings eyes and mouth are all
present and in working order now two
weeks is a remarkably short time for all
of this to happen since each imaginal
disc starts out with only about 50
cells and must multiply those into
thousands just to form a single wing and
if you checked out the chrysalis around
day 16 you might even be able to see
those brilliantly colored wings because
for some species their chrysalis turns
transparent in their final days of
metamorphosis now fully formed it's time
to hit the road the chrysalis splits
open down the center and the butterfly
escapes meanwhile a reddish liquid
spills out that's all the waste the
butterfly in a caterpillar produced
during its stay once its wings expand
and harden it's ready to mate pollinate
and slurp nectar to its heart's desire
but one of the most interesting parts of
all research suggests that butterflies
and moths can remember their caterpillar
days in one study researchers trained
moth caterpillars to associate an odor
with an electric shock so whenever the
larvae smelled it they'd move away but
even after they transformed into adult
moths they still avoided the scary smell
it makes you wonder what else they could
recall from their younger days